[Music]
congratulations on the show being
honored I was very happy to see that
after the season 1 cliffhanger but you
were indeed alive and what a journey
went on for season 2 what does it mean
to be recognized for the show to be
recognized tonight I think it's really
exciting for all of us you know we put a
lot of hard work into it and we're
talking about issues that not a lot of
other shows that kind of appeal to the
demographic we appeal to I think we're
all excited to to have that opportunity
a lot of people are very upset with the
way that the show ended this season how
do you feel about the ending you know I
think that the the ending is kind of
leaving some things open that if you're
upset about it you know hopefully we'll
have another season to be able to really
dive into that and I think that people
felt similarly about the first season
and then I hope we'll be able to do that
again where would you like to see Alex
go in a potential season 3 you know I
just hope that he's happy and figuring
things out and not being too hard on
himself ultimately I think everyone's
always growing and changing and Alex
certainly is and so hopefully yeah
growing and becoming himself how do you
think he feels about just and Justin
seemingly reconciling yeah well I think
that he doesn't really know yet so I
would imagine that he would be you feel
a bit heartbroken hopefully we'll get to
find out I was sad to see that Katherine
Langford instagrams
seemingly a farewell to Hanna what did
you take away from that Instagram you
know I think that there's always a place
for her in the show you know it kind of
started with her and she she plays such
a big part even when she's not in the
show you know we're still kind of
handling her story a lot of us and so I
think there's always room for her to be
there
[Music]